as the number of cases and the number of
deaths from coronavirus amount the
economic impact is also starting to
become clearer most obvious is the
effect on tourism you've got travel
restrictions in place and that means
they'll almost certainly be a big impact
particularly on Asian countries heavily
reliant on Chinese tourism spending and
while Chinese tourism has been growing
in the UK it's still a very small part
about 2 percent of the total the other
impact of course is on the plumbing of
the economic system China is still the
world's factory where most stuff is made
and now many of those factories are
being shuttered we've heard from Apple
for instance it's yet to work out just
how much the impact of coronavirus is
going to be after some of the factories
that supply its goods were closed that
they're slated to it reopen next week
one of Apple's main suppliers Foxconn
says customers could start to feel the
effects if factory closures are extended
for longer than that and you've got H&M
you've got jlr own a Tartar Sony and
Nike all saying they could be hit by
factory and store closures and is also
affected Dale tecar Yorkshire based
company that makes circuit boards with
parts from China they've had to look for
other suppliers to mitigate the impact
the factory that supplies materials to
us was on lockdown it was in the
affected province we have been able to
resource and find alternative materials
but there's been price implications dale
tech has taken the view that we will
absorb the costs for our customers in
the short term so we're expecting this
to be a short-term hiccup does that mean
you're likely to see shortages in shops
certainly not yet it's a question of
retailers working down their stockpiles
and looking as a source from alternative
countries but there could be a knock-on
effect on global growth although the
Chinese government have pumped nearly 80
billion dollars of liquidity into the
system it's about 60 billion pounds
Barclays reckons slower Chinese growth
could drag down global growth from
around three point three percent to
three percent this year and it's already
had a bearing on the oil price now down
to $55 70 cents a barrel that is the
lowest it's been since 2018 and it comes
an awkward time for the UK there were
hopes that the economy was going to
start bouncing back
from weak growth at the end of last year
and this morning we had a survey of the
services sector pointed towards the
strongest growth in a year and a half
fifty three point three the number on
the composite PMI but economists fear
that some of that big bounce-back could
be threatened by coronavirus especially
if the outbreaks aren't contained and if
it's spread continues